it's an NHS first in a hospital of this
size
this robot is assisting surgeons to
replace hips and knees and they hope cut
down waiting times patients have had to
wait far too long for their joint
Replacements we used to be offering
18-week weight so you'd be referred from
your GP you'd come in and have your
surgery usually within 18 weeks covered
unfortunately has given us a backlog of
one to two years
[Music]
before surgery
the robot arm guides the doctor to
remove the bone
the margin for error is Tiny here the
robot simply won't allow Cuts Beyond
half a millimeter out of line
this has been quite an extraordinary
procedure to witness and the team here
hope that using robotics in this way on
the NHS will mean better outcomes for
individual patients like this one but
also help relieve some of the pressures
the service is seeing as a whole
at a time when the NHS is under strain
and scrutiny about staff wages the robot
arm is a significant investment at 1.8
million pounds normally this is the
domain of the private sector the
evidence to support its use in terms of
early benefits in terms of soft tissue
damage reduction and thereby pain will
probably translate into reduced length
of stay the quicker we can get our
patients out the sooner we can get the
ones that have been waiting longer in
after two hours surgery is done if he
passes all of our physio assessments
we'll have him home tomorrow afternoon
it's incredible really isn't it yeah it
is um it is but I think that's that's
what this technology is going to give us
help reduce those length of stays help
get us better patient outcomes
funding for this robot has come from a
special Innovation Grant it's been hard
fought for but is pioneering for patient
care
Sky News Warsaw